bien éléments essentiels qui sont les
six à dix millions de français qui sont
aujourd'hui immunisés et dont ce groupe
appelé le groupe à pour hypothèse pour
un peu conceptualiser les choses va
aller de façon croissante et et va être
véritablement une force humaine qui va
être à risque qui va être sans risque ni
pour elle ni pour les autres donc il y a
déjà toutes ces personnes là qui peuvent
qu'y qui peuvent servir dans les garde
dans son qui peuvent en tout cas être
être utile dans une dans une interaction
sociale
donc voilà il ya plus de risques a
renvoyé ses 12 millions et demi des
colliers aujourd'hui parce qu'évidemment
le scénario noir que tout le monde
essaie d'éviter que tout le monde a en
tête c'est la deuxième vague qui la
ferait passer d'une tragédie à un
cataclysme
parce que si on est généreux contaminer
l'ensemble de la population dans deux
mois évidemment la ce est absolument
catastrophique
donc voilà on pense que c'est un risque
évitables il ya une incohérence aussi
c'est qu'on permet aux étudiants de qui
sont eux capables de gérer les gestes
barrière de ne pas aller en cours
donc là j'avoue que c'est une c'est une
incohérence qui me dépasse un petit peu
alors oui ce qui est probable c'est
qu'en mettant les remettant les enfants
à l'école on espère que les parents
pourront retourner travailler
alors que les élèves de du supérieur ne
ne sont pas dépendants de leurs parents
7 jours/7 enjeux économiques qui a été
habillé d'un enjeu social mais mais qui
est un enjeu économique mais mais encore
une fois par le da mois de cours on va
sortir de deux mois de confinement
donc je pense personnellement que c'est
plutôt un geste politique parce que
c'est vrai pour les familles cette forme
de soulagement on verra c'est à dire que
se dire que bon alors on va plus avoir
les enfants on va retrouver un petit peu
une vie normale mais encore une fois il
faut voir que il ya ce risque de
deuxième vague est quand même le premier
risque à éviter et on le prend
[Musique]